immigrants a word that's too often
followed by criminals illegal immigrant
criminals they've got a respect American
law they do not pay taxes and they're
taking your jobs perceptions or facts
let's take a look at what the numbers
tell us first assertion immigrants
increase the crime rate sure an
estimated 11 million undocumented
immigrants are in violation of American
immigration policies but overall FBI
data shows that over a span of 20 years
crime has dropped violent crime in
particular has almost halved all while
the undocumented immigrant population
tripled last year US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement removed 139 thousand
three hundred and sixty eight
undocumented immigrants that were
previously convicted of a crime then
there's a view that undocumented
immigrants are taking jobs from
Americans it's argued they're willing to
accept lower wages and poor working
conditions but the data shows it may be
more about skills
it's estimated that 8.1 million
undocumented immigrants are working or
looking for work which is about 5.1
percent of the nation's labor force yet
in specific jobs like farming cleaning
and maintenance and construction
undocumented workers make it much larger
percentages of each sector and they're
more likely to do those jobs because
they don't necessarily require fluency
in English or a high school or college
diploma because 47% of undocumented
immigrants have less than a high school
education while only 8% of us board
residents have not graduated from high
school
that's why native-born low-skilled
workers are likely to be cashiers truck
drivers and waiters so what about the
claim that undocumented immigrants
aren't paying any taxes well they
actually pay more than 11 billion
dollars each year in sales property and
income taxes wait income tax that's
right
many undocumented immigrants have ITIN
numbers and feed into the tax system
that way
and at the u.s. legalized all those
immigrant statuses the additional taxes
they would pay would be an estimated two
billion dollars for roads schools and
services that's more than some tax
avoiding Americans right